[Applause]
I want a White House Press Secretary
Kareem jean-pierre's favorite ways to
dodge questions is by claiming that
she's afraid of violating the Hatch Act
which is supposed to limit how much she
and other federal employees can talk
about politics now unfortunately for
Kareem Jean-Pierre an independent agency
is now determined that she in fact
violated the Hatch Act several times by
constantly mentioning quote Maga
Republicans at the podium but guess what
according to axios the White House isn't
stopping from going after Maga
Republicans those evil rascally people
that actually believe in energy
Independence secure border Law and Order
of tough National Defense and not awoke
military those people anyway also
tonight former president Barack Obama
he's now the latest Democrat to attack
Senator Tim Scott's views on the issues
of race relations in America now Barack
um I know you're probably watching
with that that be the history that you
learn from your pastor of over 20 years
Jeremiah Wright Black Liberation
theology just to remind our audience in
case they forgot here's barack's
preacher for over two decades the Sunday
after 9 11 2001.
no no no no not God Bless America God
damn America that's in the Bible now we
are indignant
because the stuff we have done overseas
is now brought right back into our own
front yards
America's chickens
are coming home
to roost now to his credit Senator Scott
fired back during an interview with the
great one Mark Levin correctly noting
that Barack Obama did not exactly heal
racial divisions as he as president and
you can hear more from Tim Scott himself
next Tuesday we have a town hall it's in
Myrtle Beach South Carolina
the tickets are free just go to
hannity.com we hope you'll come out and
join us here now with reaction Fox News
contributor Leo 2.0 Terrell
crowd favorite the author of the brand
new book that's now in bookstores all
across the country amazon.com
hannity.com the puppeteers Jason
Chaffetz is with us
all right Leo I'll give you first crack
at it so you know I really find this
insulting that these constant attacks
you know I don't know what's worse uh
Barack Obama who stayed in the pews of
Reverend Wright and was Pals with
Bernadine Dorn and Bel Airs uh or the
likes of a a liberal like joyless Behar
lecturing an African-American man on the
black experience in America
I I think Obama is really the problem
Barack Obama obtained the highest
position in the country president he has
reaped the benefits of everything about
this Grace Nation he could have put the
race card to an end during his eight
years as president however he did just
the opposite he doubled down the race
card he gave in to Black lives matter he
gave in to Ferguson this man has enjoyed
the benefits of everything in this great
country he was basically he won his
first election in Iowa when he plays the
race car and says that this country
still has the the the remnants of of
discrimination he is not being honest
and what happens is he has set back race
relations when he had opportunity to
really bury the race card Sean you know
there are three groups that I see Jason
Chaffetz that it's fair game to say
anything you want about him in this in
this day and age of woke and political
correctness seems like he can make any
attack you want against an
African-American conservative it seems
like you can make a tax against anyone
that identifies as a Christian or the
wife uh or girlfriend of any
Conservative candidate that's prominent
and likely running for president or
president
they seem like no rules apply for them
you're going to tack all you want yeah I
yeah I I think you're exactly right Sean
look here's the problem I have with
President Obama first of all he gave us
Joe Biden he pulled the bat out of
obscurity and what made him the vice
president United States and all they did
is work to divide America and the reason
they don't like a senator Tim Scott is
Senator Tim Scott has a positive message
an uplifting message a unifying message
he's he's about opportunity zones and
self-reliance and conservative
principles he's also really good on
school choice and making sure that
charter schools are something in this in
this country and uplifting all Americans
that's a direct threat to Barack Obama
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris that's why
they want to try to take down Senator
Tim Scott you know Leo I gotta ask you
have you experienced this since you
became 2.0 and and evolved out of 1.0
you know I'll tell you right now not as
much but yes because the race card shot
is the power and control of the
democratic party you take the race card
away from them they don't have the black
vote but more black Americans are
leaving the Democratic party they have
they have basically smelled the coffee
and they're moving to the right they
have become like myself a trump
Republican and I think the basic line is
this opportunity exists on the right and
if you want to be completely dependent
on the Democratic Kool-Aid as far as
Government will do everything you buy
into the Barack Obama game plan and what
I'm telling you is most black Americans
have rejected that and they continue to
reject it Sean all right uh Leo 2.0
Terrell now by the way Jason's book uh
the puppeteers in bookstores out this
week uh all across the country
amazon.com hannity.com uh thank you both
for being with us hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
us you will not get it anywhere else